Actually, have you gone through the admission phase one training?
Yes, sir. I watched two videos of that. The state setup and transaction mapping and token money.
Yes, sir. But I have some doubts in transaction mapping, like I did all correct in my opinion.
But when I go into application data, I am not able to show the transaction.
For example, I am putting 1000 rupees in the registration.
So, it is not coming that we can collect that 1000 rupees.
And I am not able to go to the next stage.
As it is shown in the videos, it is written that you can go to the next stage.
So, I am not able to do that.
No worries, we will check those particular doubts as the ending of this particular meeting.
But before that, the basic part is clear to you.
About the setup, about how to do the application setup and all that particular part.
Yes, I know.
And what about you, Sarita?
Yes, sir. It is clear. I also watched the first two videos.
Perfect. So guys, today we will cover the respective advanced part of the CRM.
Basic things are known to everyone.
How to do the lead out, how to do the basic setup.
That part is easy for everyone.
But what the complex part is, now you guys are having the counsellor mapping part.
After that, you guys are having the admission lead logs part.
You guys are having multiple reports which are at the advanced level.
So, going back to the setup directly.
Because I guess everyone is clear about the admission leads.
It is clear to add tags, add follow-ups, add visits.
Does anyone have any doubts about this?
No, sir. It is clear.
Akhshat?
Sir, this one is not in the videos.
In the recordings, follow-ups are not there yet.
Like the Zoho integration, tags and counsellor mapping part.
We will cover the counsellor mapping part now.
My point is, how to add the admission leads page or follow-up, how to add tags. Is that clear?
No, sir. It is not in the videos yet.
It was not taught in the previous videos.
What about you Tanvi and Bhavan?
Sir, I guess this part has not been done yet.
It has not been done yet.
So, let's do one thing.
Let's cover this part as well.
Post that, we will move on to the further advanced part.
Basically, this part is clear to you.
You just have to come on to the application number setup.
Then, what sort of stages you guys need.
After that, for any sort of transaction, you have to give the transaction number.
And furthermore, you guys are having the admission leads part.
Sorry, the heads part.
You have to collect the heads.
Token money is clear enough to all of you.
Yes, sir.
After that, what we have is admission tags.
I will explain it now.
What was our admission source?
Basically, whenever you are receiving any particular of the lead or
if you are adding it manually, you have to select a respective source.
So, this source part will also be clear.
Yes, sir.
Now, what is the point?
Let's do the rest of the things now.
Starting with the admission tag.
Basically, try to understand that you have a lead.
And considering yourself as a counselor.
And you have to work on that particular lead.
So, when you are working on that, there could be multiple circumstances
as to what the student replied to you.
Student could be interested.
Student may not be interested.
Student could come for the visit to the campus.
And at the end, the student replied.
So, student can be a not interested one as well.
So, basically, what we do is, on the leads page,
or any page on which you are working,
taking an example, I have a fresh lead.
I have put a filter for not engaged.
I will tell you what is the use of filters.
What does not engaged mean?
That you have leads in the system.
But the counselor has not been done any kind of activity
with that particular lead.
So, after doing the not engaged filter,
after doing the not engaged filter,
you are having these red ribbons over there.
So, the leads where there is no activity,
those are marked with these red ribbons.
This makes it clear that this lead is untouched lead.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Or for example, if there is any sort of lead
where there is some activity,
for example, there is an engaged lead,
either with the completed follow-up or the pending follow-up.
So, in that case, the ribbon does not come.
It does not come in this case.
Is it okay?
Guys, is it okay?
Yes, sir.
Moving back to the not engaged.
Now, basically, when you work on a lead,
you will select a respective tag.
Based on the conversation you have done with the student.
If the student is interested, may be interested,
after coming forward with it, you will select the respective tag.
So, if the tag is positive,
the system will ask you to add a follow-up
in which you will be able to add the date,
you will be able to add the time,
you will be able to add the remark.
Taking an example, I selected a date here.
After selecting the date, I put a remark here
and clicked on update.
So, automatically, my tag has been updated.
Now, what bad is,
I had just selected the not engaged lead.
So, my engaged with pending one is not showing.
By default, you have to use both the shows.
I have put it on coming forward with it.
I have put it on every tag.
I will follow the view here.
So, it has just been added.
Is this thing clear?
Yes, sir.
What are you saying?
Were you saying something?
No, sir.
So, this much is clear.
Now, the point is,
how did you make this tag?
And why did you get a follow-up call?
For example, if I put interested in this,
then I got a follow-up call.
If I marked it as not interested or something else,
course not available or not attending or not eligible,
then the system asked you for a negative tag.
Both are different.
You are putting a follow-up in one.
In one case, you are putting a negative remark.
So, how is this set?
In which case, your follow-up will come?
In which case, your remark will come?
Is it clear?
There are two things.
When you put a tag on any particular lead,
either it would ask you a follow-up
or it would ask you a remark.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Now, the point is,
how will we set this?
Who will get positive?
Who will get negative?
So, you just have to come into the admission setup.
Click on the admission master and the admission tags.
From here, you can make admission tags.
Click on the add new details.
Whatever tag you want to give,
for example, I have taken a test tag.
Whatever color combination you want to give,
on the basis of your requirement,
you can give it by adjusting from here.
Now, the point is the labels.
The labels that come here,
your positive label and the negative label.
So, if you select positive,
then in that case,
it would ask you a follow-up.
Is it okay?
Yes, sir.
If you select negative,
then it would ask you a negative remark.
Simple, nothing else.
Nothing like rocket science.
You can create tags here
by coming to this page.
Different colors.
I will tell you one thing.
It is a little important.
Make sure you remember it forever.
What happens with us, basically,
if any lead comes in the system,
if it comes from the same number again,
then what does our system do?
It marks it as duplicate.
But how do you make duplicate tags?
That is the important thing.
I am deleting it now.
I have saved it here.
To make duplicate tags,
it is fixed.
You don't have to change anything in it.
Come to add new details.
Write duplicate properly.
There should be no space at the end
or in the starting.
After that, choose a random color.
After choosing a random color,
mark it as negative and save it.
Is this clear?
Yes, sir.
Now, what will you do with it?
Change the hex value of that random tag.
You have to zero this as well.
Zero it from here.
And then save it.
This will create duplicate tags.
Is this clear?
Yes, sir.
Good.
Now, the point is,
if you mark every lead as duplicate,
you won't even know
which lead came first.
The main lead, I would say.
In that case,
we will make a new tag.
That is Duplicate Primary.
Duplicate Primary will be extra in this.
Select any color.
Add labels.
Positive, negative, whatever.
In general, it will be positive.
After that, change the hex value to black.
Change it to black.
From here, RGB.
Zero.
And save it.
Is this clear?
Why are we making duplicate and duplicate primary?
Do you understand?
Yes, sir.
I will show you an example.
I added a lead.
For example,
I added a lead from a random number.
The lead was captured in the system.
It was created here.
Now, if I create a new lead from the same number,
the system will pop up.
The lead is already existing
But what you have to do for that,
you have to set up
a lead from any mobile number or from any other field.
After that,
if you still want to add a lead,
you will add it as duplicate query.
You will give names,
you will select your source.
I will tell you what campus visit rate is.
So, what did the system do?
Automatically, the first lead,
what did it do? Duplicate Primary.
And after that,
the lead we added, what did it do?
Duplicate.
Now, all the leads added from the same number
in the system will be duplicated.
So, what will Duplicate Primary do?
It will help you in checking
which was the first lead
with the same number.
Is this point clear?
This is really important if you are
at any college level
or at any university level.
Guys, is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Perfect.
Now, the point is,
this admission leads page,
what data does it show you?
The first data you have is
your fresh leads.
Whether you have leads today
or old leads,
no work has been done on them.
Fresh leads means your not engaged leads.
Then it shows you the leads
of those particular follow-ups
which are pending.
So, by default,
in the system, only two
statuses are ticked.
Not engaged or
engaged with pending follow-up.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
By default,
only positive tags are selected
because if you
mark any lead with a negative tag,
for example,
the student is not interested
or the course is not available,
then in that case,
the counselor will have
a lot of lead data.
For example, being an adult,
I have 10,000 leads.
Imagine if the counselor
keeps seeing all the data
which is useless.
So, what we do is,
if I mark this lead,
I can copy it.
So, what I can do is,
I marked it,
not able to take decision,
not interested,
tagged, remarked,
saved.
My lead is gone.
If I search this lead,
the system won't show me the lead.
Do you understand?
How did it happen?
Guys, will you say something?
Babay, explain why this happened?
Why is the lead not showing?
Babay, am I available?
Yes, sir.
Will you tell me once?
He is asking.
I will explain again.
What we did is,
we gave a negative tag to that lead.
What this page does is,
by default,
only the positive tag is selected in the filter.
So, when the positive tag is selected,
the negative tag of any lead
will not be visible.
So, what did I do to this lead?
I gave a negative tag to this lead.
So, what did the system do to it?
Because of filters,
it won't show the data.
But if I still want to check
if any lead exists from this number,
then I have two ways.
Either I can select the respective filter from here.
I selected from here,
not interested, click on go.
And search this application.
So, I got this lead.
Is this thing clear?
What did I do? I selected tag,
respective, not interested.
And from here, I selected status.
Engaged with pending and completed follow.
And that application was added.
So, I got the application.
This is the first process.
What is the second process?
I will reload it.
It applies the by default filters.
Then, you will turn on global search.
And you don't have to change anything.
Filters will be as it is.
You will not select any tag from here.
Not interested or anything.
You will only turn on global search.
And if you add the application number,
it will be visible.
I understand. Global search point
is also clear and not interested.
Why did you remove it?
Is it clear or not?
Yes, sir.
It is clear.
Any doubt?
Yes, sir.
Now, the point is,
it is clear that you can add tags from here.
Now, what do we have here?
We have to add follow ups directly.
You can add follow ups directly.
You have to add visit.
What does visit mean?
If a student visits the campus,
you can record it from here.
For example, if he comes tomorrow,
he will visit on the day after tomorrow.
If he comes the day after tomorrow,
From here, you have to add a note.
You have to make calls.
IVR should be integrated for calls.
Only then it can be called.
Otherwise, the call will not go.
The call will fail.
After that, you have to add a note
for the student.
You have to talk to the student.
You have to give specific information
After that, you will be able to
check the timeline of the student.
When the application was created,
who created it,
which email to check,
what email was sent to the student,
you can check from here.
All the activities you do in this
post that you have is
open WhatsApp.
Let me show you
what it works like.
Basically,
when I click on any student's
open WhatsApp,
my WhatsApp web will be opened.
My name is passed in it.
The name of the entity is passed.
You will be directly on open WhatsApp.
Your respective counselor's WhatsApp
will be logged in and he can directly
communicate with the student.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Now, the student's name
can be anything.
Here is Sagar Babu.
I had booked Sagar Babu in this.
Sagar Babu is coming.
The system will automatically
take your number from there.
You will not need to type manually.
Is it clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Now, the point is,
you can filter the data accordingly.
You have to filter the course-wise data.
You have to filter counselor-wise data.
You have to filter source-wise data.
You have to filter status-wise data.
Wait a minute.
Is this clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Next time,
I will turn on the camera and tell everyone.
But the mic too.
This part is clear enough.
Moving to the setup again.
Is the tag part clear, guys?
Is there any doubt in the tag?
No, sir.
We will not do the seats part.
The source part will be clear.
Why do we add sources?
Now, the point is the source group.
In the case of source group,
for example,
we have made 10 sources in our system.
So, some entities
group the sources.
Group in the sense that
organic sources excite,
inorganic sources excite,
social media related sources excite.
Take an example.
I have created organic.
In organic,
I have selected website, my operator,
intag and
walk-in direct.
Then, I have selected inorganic.
Inorganic
is the spelling.
In organic,
I have selected social media,
WhatsApp,
online admission
and so on.
Then, we have third party vendors.
We have selected them separately.
In third party vendors,
we have career mantra, college duniya,
siksha planar, affinity,
all these are kept.
When you go to the source-wise report,
the data will be
combined and come to you.
Do you understand?
Inorganic is separated,
third party vendors are separated.
Others, which we have not put anywhere,
are separated. Is that clear?
Now, when you expand them,
you will get all the information
after expanding.
There was intag, website,
nothing. Now, when you print it,
it will be printed.
So, admission,
going to the source group,
this is the work.
Is that clear, guys?
Yes, sir.
Moving to the next point.
Admission seats,
not mandatory as of now.
Councillor mapper does.
Now, the point is,
whatever lead you get in the system,
it is assigned to some councillor.
Some councillor works on it.
So, from this
particular councillor mapper settings,
what you can do, you guys can
able to map the councillors
for the courses
as well and for the sources
as well.
Specific sources, taking an example,
specific sources selected,
reference selected, intag selected.
So, you can set multiple councillors
as well.
This source
and all the leads
from these particular
sources, they will go to these three persons.
Automatically.
You will not need to assign again and again.
So, what will the system do?
It will assign one by one, one lead to Sumit,
one lead to Himanshi, one lead to Deepa.
And on the process of round robin,
it will assign one by one.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
If any particular client
has a councillor
who works on all the courses,
then in that case, you will have
to select all of them
one by one.
After that, you will not make
multiple engineering courses.
There will be only one engineering course,
and one computer application course.
In that, you will select all the councillors.
So, one lead goes to him, one lead goes to the other,
the other goes to the fourth, and so on.
Okay?
Yes, sir.
What is this process called?
Councillor mapper.
Councillor mapper is the page.
From which process it is assigned,
what is it called?
Round robin.
Yes.
Now, the point is, round robin also
happens in two ways.
I will explain.
One is your all, another one is your device.
In the case of all, guys, what happens is
taking an example, you have four people in the meeting.
Suppose we have only three people in the meeting.
So, I gave all the information
Is it clear?
You were first, I explained everything to you.
Bhavya came late.
So, because Bhavya came late,
I have to give the starting information
to Bhavya again.
So that you guys come at an equal level.
So that I can proceed further.
Yes.
Bhavya, thank you for being the example here.
Right?
So, basically, what I will do is
I will hold the three of you for that time.
Right?
And I will transfer all the information
that I gave to the three of you to Bhavya first.
When all four of you come at the same level,
after that we will move to the next level.
What I mean to say is, suppose
there are three councillors.
They have leads of 10, 10, 10, 10.
One councillor came, a new one
was added to the system.
He does not have any lead.
So, what will the system do?
To balance the load of the other three councillors,
it will assign 10 first.
The new councillor will assign 10 first.
When he is equal to 10, 10, 10,
then one and one will start to be assigned.
Is it clear, guys?
What does all mean in the round problem?
Yes, sir. It is clear.
Very good.
Next, we have the devise.
Now, another one is the devise.
In the case of devise,
the system has no meaning.
Any councillor can be added anytime.
Whether it is added today,
or after 10 days, or after a month.
One person will have 1000 leads.
So, the system will not do
that the new one will be transferred to the new one.
What will it do?
As on date, it will assign one by one.
Is it clear?
This is important.
Sir, in devise,
suppose all the leads
will go to one person on Monday.
Will this happen?
No, I will tell you again.
In the case of all,
for example,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
three people worked for three days.
On Monday, another new councillor joined.
So, in the case of all,
all the leads will go to the new one on Monday.
Then, when your load will be balanced,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
and Monday,
then, until it is balanced,
the other three councillors
will not have any lead assigned.
But in the case of devise,
on Monday,
you worked for three councillors,
Friday, Saturday,
and Sunday, you worked for three councillors.
On Monday, a new councillor
was added to the system.
So, the system will not hold those three councillors.
The system will assign them in the same way.
Suppose, the first lead comes,
it gives one, the second one,
the third one, the fourth one,
the fourth one, the one added on Monday,
it will start again.
1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Is it clear?
Devise and all?
Yes.
Okay, this is all done.
Now, the point is duplicate field master.
Duplicate field master,
which I just showed you a pop-up
from the same mobile number
when I added the lead,
it had showed the respective pop-up
that this lead already exists
within the system.
So, from here, you select the field
on which you want to check.
If we get the same field again,
then the system will show you the pop-up.
In general, our phone number
remains the same.
It is very rare in some cases
that your Aadhaar card
is set, okay,
your, I would say,
10th class roll number is set,
12th class roll number is set,
it remains in very rare cases.
Phone number remains mostly in cases.
Okay, so on which field
your pop-up will depend on?
It depends on this particular
phone number.
Clearance is?
Very good.
Then we have my operator config,
IVR, area B,
explain, I will do both of these later.
Let's move on to this particular
admission team.
Now, basically, guys,
see, in our universities
and colleges, in their case,
there are very rare cases,
where your outreach team is different,
okay, inside team is different
for the admissions,
so both teams do not share
the data of the leads.
Okay, let's take an example.
Here is a senior most person,
okay, after that,
he has two sub-branches.
Can you see what I am drawing on my screen?
Yes, sir.
Okay, take an example,
here we have a person,
there are two teams in the branches below him,
one here and one there.
Okay, the senior most person
can see the data of this team
and this team,
but these two guys cannot see
each other's data.
Okay, but let's take an example,
there will be branches below this team,
right, so this guy can see
his team's data,
this guy can see his team's data,
but this senior most person
can see his team's data,
this guy can see his team's data,
but these two cannot see each other's data.
After that, the people in the branches below
cannot see each other's data.
Understood?
So what we do,
there are very rare cases in which
there is a team structure, otherwise
there is only a single most senior person
and there are multiple counselors below him.
There are two types of clearages,
either you are a senior most person,
there are two teams below him,
then they are divided into two teams,
or you have a single senior most person
who has multiple counselors.
If there is a single person
and multiple counselors, then there is no need
for a team, so there is no need
to follow the team structure,
just delete it and save it.
Clearage is?
Perfect. Now,
taking an example, if we have
two teams, one is your domestic,
which we have set as team lead
for Sumit Kumar,
here we have added the members
within it,
we have made Himanshi,
Shresti, we have covered Deepak,
and Anaita.
We saved it.
We added the other team for the external team.
of the external team,
your Gaurav Sachan,
he is the lead.
The people inside him,
for example,
Mani,
Pallavi,
Sukhpeeth,
now what will happen,
you have two senior
most person, one is
this, another one is this.
Within this team,
one person, one person, one person, one person,
this person can see their data,
and Gaurav
can see their data.
They can't see
their own data, counselors,
same here, they can't see
Sumit Gaurav's data,
or his team's data.
Is this clear?
Team lead can't see other's data.
Yes, team lead can't see other's data.
You can create
multiple teams here.
You can add multiple members.
One more point,
taking an example, Anaita
is also in his team,
and Anaita is also in his team.
Now what will happen,
in this case, Gaurav
can see his data,
sorry, Sumit, Gaurav
can see Anaita's data.
Now the common data
between them, both of them are visible.
In general, this doesn't happen,
but still, I told you with an example,
if a question comes up tomorrow,
you will say, in that case,
both of them can see their data.
But still, Sumit
can't see Gaurav's data.
Whose data are they seeing?
They can see their common team member's data.
It's not like,
if we merge Anaita here,
then its Pallavi's data
can be seen by Sumit, or Deepa's data
can be seen by Gaurav.
Gaurav and Sumit, both
can only see Anaita's data,
combined, whatever is common.
Are things getting clear, guys?
Or is it coming from above?
No, sir, it's clear.
Both of them will be able to see
the common data of Anaita.
Okay, team's part is also clear.
Okay, now from the team's part,
I had left a point in the filter.
Damn, I clicked on the Excel file.
Okay, I clicked on the filter.
Here, the show member details comes up.
Basically, what happens is,
you can filter from here,
which counselor's data you want.
Okay, if you want Deepa's data,
then Deepa's data is 253.
Okay, you want someone else's counselor's data,
you put Savita's data, Savita's data comes to you.
Okay, it's not there.
Now, the point is,
let's take an example,
Deepa is, okay,
I clicked on that,
I got the 253 data.
But Deepa was in Sumit's team.
How much data does Sumit have now?
725.
Okay, but if I
turn on its show member detail also,
then what will show member detail do?
All the members in his team
will also get their data visible.
Okay, 1389 something.
Do you understand the point?
What happened to the filter when we detailed the show member?
Yes, sir.
When our toggle was off,
in the case of off,
only Sumit's data came to us.
Okay.
But when we turned on
the members' toggle,
then what did the system do in that case?
It showed all the leads of its members
together.
Because a counselor,
it's a simple thing, counselor,
he is also working as a counselor,
but he is also in his team,
so how will he see the data of his team?
He will see the data from this filter.
This is your show member detail filter.
Is it clear?
Yes, sir.
Very nice.
Now comes the admission
follow-up page.
Basically, guys,
you add any follow-up,
you can see it in the lead,
but you need collective data
to see where all the follow-ups are added.
So you will come to the follow-up page,
here you will get all the data.
There are 27,912
follow-ups in total.
What can be the multiple follow-ups
The same lead mark can be seen again,
like this one.
The lead is same, one follow-up is completed,
one follow-up pending.
Here you will see all follow-ups,
here you will see today's follow-up,
today's follow-ups are planned.
Upcoming follow-ups are
what you need to complete
in future.
Overdue follow-ups are
the pending follow-ups.
Then you have the completed
follow-ups, which are completed.
Here you can also check
the follow-ups by setting the start date and end date.
You can check how many are completed
and how many are pending.
This is just a report kind of.
Is there any doubt in this?
No, sir.
Now you will get the admission leads
log page.
Isn't it too much?
Or you can keep this much.
If it is too much,
Okay, perfect.
Now we have this admission leads log page.
Basically, guys, what happens is
you get the leads from IVR.
You can manage the other sources
such as website, landing page.
One minute, guys.
So basically, if you have
any exercise sources,
you are getting the leads.
You are managing them.
But in the case of IVR, you need
call data as well.
You convert the calls into
logs in the lead.
You are receiving the calls directly
into this particular page and then
you are converting them into
a lead log.
Logs are created.
But how to add them in the lead,
you will do it from here.
Basically, what happens is
we integrate our IVR with
the respective partner.
So the calls that come to the counselors
will automatically land in this.
It is a received call, it is a missed call.
You can check which two counselors
you have picked.
By default, caller info and all these things
are blank because you don't know
whose phone it is on the phone.
It comes from random numbers.
So when you call back the student,
then post discussion with the student,
you will add the name.
I have added one in 7.
I have added a lead here.
I have added which stream it is in.
I mean, my call is done.
Now the point is you can also check
the recording of the call directly.
You will have to log in.
So from here you can check
the output of the calls.
Is that clear, Rajesh?
Yes, sir.
Very good.
So from here,
you can check the respective
recordings.
From here, you have to convert the log.
So you can also convert from here.
From here, you have to reject
that if the student is not interested,
then you can also reject it.
If you have called and the student
has not picked the call, then you can
ask for the call note.
Here you have multiple filters.
You can check the converted logs
from here.
So you will know how much
we have converted from here.
You can also check how many pending
logs are there.
You can also check the call status
and how many received calls you have.
If you want specific
counsellor data,
you can also do that.
Sir, what is this source?
What is this source?
Basically, the source here,
the My Operator, is your IBR partner.
So that is why we have a source here.
So we also have a My Operator.
And set my operator config
and push set.
So we have the My Operator config.
Here is the secret token
salient ID, the IBR ID
and the PID ID.
Ok, let's not go further on this part.
Otherwise, you will get confused.
All that you have done, have been clear yours?
Yes sir.
amelion logo
Akshat...
Sir, what is
My operator is an IVR.
The calls that come to your counselors or your admission team,
they are directly linked to an app.
If you have called for an admission, it goes to the IVR number
and then it connects to your counselor.
My operator is a mediator.
The student calls first to the IVR.
The IVR checks which counselor is free at that time.
They transfer the call to the counselor.
When the call is transferred to the counselor and the student creates it,
the IVR mediator keeps getting logs
that this call was hit, this call was reverted,
this response came that it was picked, missed, talked for a long time.
Then the data is pushed to us.
My operator is an IVR
which is able to get the records
of those particular calls.
Then it hits back to us.
In the advanced one, I guess, a lot is completed.
We are left with the report sections only.
Any doubts?
In this part.
We will have the Q&A session again by Akshay.
Because it is already 6.22.